okay we have some breaking news for you  now and the conspiracy theorist Alex  Jones has been ordered by a jury at a  Connecticut court to pay  965 million dollars to the people who  suffered as a result of his false claim  that the Sandy Hook Elementary School  shooting never happened that's just come  into us so that's  965 million dollar fine to be paid to  the people who suffered as a result of  conspiracy theorist Alex Jones you'll  remember he were broadcast on Infowars  and repeatedly said that he didn't  believe the Sandy Hook shooting took  place he said at one point that um the  the news coverage was all actors  um and it was a part of a plot to take  away people's guns so uh Alex Jones has  been now ordered to pay 965  million dollars to presumably the  families of the Sandy Hook school  shooting victims